er ist passiert am hellichten tag in
einer s-bahn in berlin eine junge frau
wurde zunächst angepöbelt und dann auch
körperlich angegriffen
am ende sogar aus dem waggon auf einen
bahnsteig geschubst eingegriffen hat
fast niemand aber die tat wurde gefilmt
es ist eine situation die niemand
erleben möchte ein streit in der s-bahn
eskaliert hier aufnahmen vom montag aus
berlin ein mann brüllt aggressiv immer
wieder eine frau an die am boden neben
ihrem hund kniet nur wenige fahrgäste
sind in der nähe zwischen den
aggressiven mann und die verängstigte
frau stellt sich niemand als die bahn am
nächsten bahnhof anhält schutz der mann
sein opfer auf den bahnsteig dann läuft
er weg für die umstehenden fahrgäste ist
das eine schwierige situation auf die
hilfeschreie der frau versichern sie sie
würden die polizei alarmieren
auch auf englisch aber hätten sie mehr
unternehmen können und hätte der
angreifer festgehalten oder verfolgt
werden sollen
die polizei konnte den mann inzwischen
identifizieren und hat ermittlungen
aufgenommen
aber sie betont auch dass ein schnelles
eingreifen unter umständen mehr hilft
als videos der tat später über soziale
netzwerke zu verbreiten und mein kollege
peter wege steht jetzt an dem bahnsteig
an denen es zu diesem vorfall gekommen
ist gemeinsam mit einem augenzeuge
jan ehlen ich stehe hier am bahnhof
deren seestraße in berlin hier kam es am
montagmittag zu der brutalen attacke auf
die junge frau in der s-bahn die frau
wurde dann wie wir im video gesehen
haben hier an dem an der stelle auf dem
bahnsteig auf dem bahnsteig geschubst
und brutal geschlagen
der täter konnte zuerst fliehen wurde
dann aber gestern direkt hier in der
nähe gefasst wie die bundespolizei
mitgeteilt hat und jetzt bei mir ist
augenzeuge robert lehmann den wir auch
in dem video gesehen haben der er mit
dem rucksack robert jetzt die ganze
situation die ganze attacke mitbekommen
was hast du beobachtet ja ich habe erst
mal mitbekommen
s bahnhof zuvor dieser diesem s-bahnhof
hier in hohenschönhausen das geschrei
war da bin ich auch in der s bahn
eingestiegen
der vorfall das geschrei ging dann in
der s-bahn weiter bin dann direkt da
zudem schreitet sozusagen hingelaufen
habe wollte mich da vergewissern was da
los ist weil da jemand um hilfe
geschrien hat die ganze zeit und habe
dann gesehen wie ein mann auf eine frau
da irgendwo ein geprüft
lackiert hat ja versucht hat
einzuschüchtern in der s bahn direkt und
wie konkret bist du dann eingeschritten
ja ich hab ich habe versucht mich da
irgendwie dazwischen zu stellen wie man
im video daher sehen kann was passanten
dann auch die aufsicht in der s bahn
befanden aufgenommen haben was ja durch
die social medien ging habe versucht den
angreifer irgendwie von von von der frau
abzuwenden also dass er sich halt auf
mich erstmal fixiert dass er verstellt
hey wir gucken jetzt leute zu ist nicht
mehr ganz so einfach ist noch mal
rauszukommen
sodann ist ja geflohen
ja er hat dann versucht er sich erstmal
an hat dann hier in grenzen gehalten
ganz normal
er wollte dann aussteigen die frau hat
sich danach in die tür gestellt um ihn
halt aufzuhalten zu dessen dass er nicht
abhaut in den augenblick hat dann
der angreifer die frau eine mitgegeben
also wirklich eingeschlagen
worauf ich mir dann auch wirklich verbal
was gesagt habe vor habe ich gar nicht
gesagt haben ja wo fixiert mit meinen
augen wo ich dann gesagt hey hey hey
hallo und dann ist er halt geflohen über
die brücke hat versucht wegzulaufen ich
bin ja noch kurz hinterher ein stückchen
gelaufen aber er ist mir dann einkommen
so zu sagen du hast gesagt die frau
hatte auch blessuren im gesicht wie hast
du denn das verhalten der anderen
fahrgäste im zug wahrgenommen und was
lernst du aus der ganzen sache ja erster
weise lerne ich aus der ganzen sache
immer wieder das gleiche so zumindest zu
tun weil das ist das minimum was jeder
mensch jeder bürger eigentlich hier in
diesem land gegenüber dass ihm
gegenüberstehenden bürgers leisten kann
an zivilcourage das auf jeden fall das
was da vielleicht zu ersehen ist als
straftat oder so gleich halt unter
zeugen stattfindet ja und dass man da
nicht mehr so leicht dann rauskommt und
dass deshalb auch zum ermittlungserfolg
bei sowas auch führt und nicht wieder
falsch irgendwo dann dargestellt wird
hinterher
hast du selbst gar keine angst ja doch
ein bisschen angst hatte ich schon um
meine eigene körperliche unversehrtheit
weil wenn man
da so gegen so eine aggressive personen
gegen antritt und da die ja auf sich
aufmerksam macht dass man dass man da
sich im weg stellt dass man dann selber
da irgendwas von abt gericht mit und war
ziemlich aggressiv ja wir haben gehört
wir lernen auch durch worte durch
einfaches einschreiten kann man in
solchen situationen große hilfe leisten
und jeder bürger sollte versuchen in
solchen situationen zu helfen
zivilcourage zu zeigen und nicht einfach
nur daneben zu stehen und ganz zu tun